let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [__]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[__] them
[Music]
well happy hump day
it's wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern you know what time
that is
it's time for let's talk
the tony michaels podcast i'm the tony
michaels
reporting live
from the scene of the accident we have a
lot of stuff to talk about today
a lot of stuff to talk about today
and i'm not going to get to it all
because there's just way too much stuff
to even
fit into an hour and that is why that is
why if you have not been paying
attention i have been live streaming
for several days a week on twitch
i've been doing that i don't know if you
guys have noticed
but i decided that i would surf twitter
and tick tock we did tick tock the other
day was really fun
we would surf twitter and tick tock and
talk a lot about these subjects on a
live stream on twitch and we also
decided to go ahead and stream it on
twitter we're not doing it on youtube
yet we may we may not i don't know
so if you're not following
on twitch go over and follow uh you can
watch the live streams as we break down
all these stories when i'm surfing
twitter and tick tock and tick tock and
we're going to show a few of the videos
today
of those live streams i got some clips
from those live streams we also have
um some clips of some other tic tac
videos that are are making their way
around the internet
and i'll show you those
because we have several subjects to get
to number one
is the robert e lee statue has finally
come to the ground in richmond virginia
today so we've got that story and i
talked about that on the
on the stream uh this morning about the
robert e lee statue uh and and i think
uh we're gonna have a little clip about
that that i'm gonna show from the stream
this morning and uh
really the question that i want to know
what the robert e lee statue is who who
is going to replace robert e lee
on the perch of this monument there's a
lot of people i actually have an idea
that i'm going to propose today now i'm
not saying that this is the exact person
but this may be a candidate maybe just a
candidate of someone that could go up on
that perch of that monument
um given them a statue
and get rid of the confederate monuments
uh and even it
this person that i'm going to mention
even has confederate history it has
confederate confederate history in
richmond virginia of all places so we'll
talk about maybe maybe the candidate
that i have in mind and then you guys
can go out on the interwebs and have fun
discussing and debating that
the other story big big story that i
want to talk about here
um is the greg abbott press conference
that he had the other day and basically
said uh the exception to abortion in
texas is within that
six week period
and then he went on to uh talk about how
uh they're gonna
use the movie minority report as policy
to stop rapists so we're going to talk
about
uh greg abbott and the texas abortion
law
and i want to talk about the american uh
white male fragility christian taliban
because a lot of people have been given
a lot of [__] on the internet
about calling uh these folks down in
texas the texas taliban or the american
or the christian taliban
so i wanna i wanna i wanna reiterate
that point
and get those things straight some of
the other small stories that we may or
may not get to is uh jim jordan talking
about real americans
uh you know and and that the back scene
that vaccine mandates are un-american so
we might get to to jim i don't report
sex crimes jordan it's possible and also
his buddy matt walsh talking about how
women shouldn't be sportscasters so we
might get to that subject too
that subject to
so hang with me here this hour it should
be a fun filled hour
of beating the hell out of these
fascists
what do you guys think you think that's
what we should do you think that's what
we should do this hour
so let's start with the uh
let's start with the the
confederacy the
the original confederacy in this country
not the cheeto dust confederacy
but the original confederacy with robert
e lee
general robert e lee and his statue
coming down today i think i think i read
that that statue has been there for
almost
almost 130 years which
is about 130 years too long but
the the statute definitely should have
been taken down during the civil rights
era once civil rights act was passed
because the statue is a statement okay
it's a statement it's there for a reason
and robert e lee is not a hero and i
talked about this on this stream this
morning so again to reiterate if you're
if you're just tuning in
you might want to go download the twitch
app if you haven't already because i i
wasn't
i wasn't aware of what twitch was i
really wasn't um i thought it was just
like a gaming
streaming site or something like that
which it seems like that's the main
point of it and i've been trying to
to surf twitch a little bit to figure
out what the hell it is and i i start to
come to realize that that it's not just
gaming
um there is a ton of weird [__] on
twitch i don't know if you if you guys
go download the app don't spend too much
time in this rabbit hole because it is a
weird [__] rabbit hole
but go go look at some of the uh the
just chatting under the category just
chatting that's where i think i'll post
most of uh the streams that we do i i
wanted to do it under politics but
it's harder to find under politics so i
figured i'd just put it under just
chatting but go under that category just
chatting on on twitch especially at
night
holy actual [__]
you think you think they're
you're a weirdo now nope nope
nope doesn't hold the candle go check
out
go check out twitch at night under just
chatting you will find out that this
world has some crazy [__] in it
and not only does it have some crazy
[__] it has a lot of people
that are willing to watch these crazy
[__]
do some weird ass [__] on stream it's
[__] weird
i don't understand a lot of it i can't
figure out a lot of it i don't even know
what the hell they're talking about most
the time like
it's crazy i'm just
but what we're gonna do over there let
me explain what we're gonna do over
there
several days a week what i'm gonna do
especially on big news days where
there's a lot of stories
to keep
to keep you guys abreast of what my
opinion is because there's so many
stories coming down that it's hard to do
uh it's hard to get
everything packed into this one hour on
the podcast
and the twitch streaming is a little
more casual it's not as you know i'm not
picking out subjects and doing it for a
full hour like i am on here
we're just kind of casually doing it you
know so so check it out go download the
app
get get the app
and then you'll find me the tony
michaels or just go to
thetonymichaels.com that the twitch link
is there
but go find that
and watch that but here is the video
here's the the clip
from the stream this morning about
robert e lee and the video of them
taking down the statue that i did so let
me play that question is
what are we gonna replace it with this
is in virginia so we should you know
pick a an actual hero from virginia to
put up there
um
i think but you know so that's the
question is who who is going to be but
my tweet was robert e lee is a sucker
and a loser cause he is a [__] loser
[__] lost he's a [__] sucker
because he
he fought for slavery
uh this shouldn't be controversial this
this this idea
that it should be controversial to take
down a [__] statue of the confederate
[__] general
who fought
who
[__] traitor who fought to keep
american southern americans to own other
[__] human beings okay
okay just so we're [__] clear here
that's
oh
who he was
it's
in 2021 folks it should not be a
controversial thing to take this [__]
statue down
now if somebody wants to put it in a
[__] museum somewhere like a a
confederate you know cemetery or some
[__] and put a big plaque that says this
is where this [__] statue is at this
is why it was there give not just the
history of robert e lee but the history
of the [__] statue and why it was
there
is to send a signal
send a message right
so if if that i'm i'm fine if you want
to place a big plaque in front of and
tell the actual story of that son of a
[__] because what i say is this should
not be controversial it should not be
controversial that we take this
[__] down in a public place like
this
real americans learn their history and
know the truth
if you if you really know the truth
about robert e lee and you really know
the truth about american history you
would not want this [__] statue in a
place
that makes it seem like we are honoring
robert e lee a [__] traitor a traitor
to our country
you [__] patriots out there oh
patriots
the [__] out of here you are not
patriots if you think robert e lee is a
[__] hero he was a [__] traitor
and they lost
and someone posted a video
uh
let's see
so that was the clip from the uh
the twitch stream this morning about
robert e lee you notice you notice it
looks a little different if you're
watching this on video you notice it
looks a little different
it's kind of similar but it's a little
different than here on the podcast
and that's because i'm over on twitch so
i'm i'm trying to do uh several
different things again it's a little
more casual but the point of that clip
was
is that it's good that the robert e lee
statue is coming down because he's a
tree treasonous piece of [__]
and why that statue stood there in the
first place is beyond me
to celebrate him as a hero because he's
[__] not he's not a hero he's a hero
to traitors
i mean if you're a [__] traitor
yeah he's a [__] hero if you're a
[__] traitor to the united states of
america why do you think all these trump
humping [__] evangelicals are pissed
off that they're taking his statue down
they're pissed off that they're taking
his statue down because they're [__]
traitors they don't want the
constitution they don't want democracy
they don't want that they don't want
equal rights they don't want equity they
don't want it they don't want it it's
their white grievance that's the whole
point
we're gonna see some more
white male fragility today a [__] ton of
it here
but that's what this is
white male fragility grievance
and robert e lee was a [__] traitor
and the only [__] hero that he is too
is two [__] traitors
to this country
the land of the free the land of the
brave you know
star spangled banner and [__]
give me a [__] break you
you goddamn spread neck fake patriots
you're not even you're
pluck your head out of your [__]
asses and realize
that robert e lee
tried to overthrow the government of the
united states and what's funny about
that
what's funny about the the original
confederacy trying to overthrow the
government of the united states because
they wanted to own own other human
beings
they wanted to own other human beings as
property that's why they were trying to
you know
bang up the united states because united
states basically said you can't own
other human beings anymore
so they were they were treasonous
against the united states because the
united states wouldn't let them own
human beings
that's why there was a war you [__]
idiots
the craziest part about it all
is robert e lee didn't go to washington
and throw a rally
and encourage people to go overthrow the
constitution
in the capitol building that didn't
happen oh
but during the cheeto dust confederacy
something like that might have happened
and those are the people who want his
statue to remain up there
i wonder why it seems convenient it
seems convenient that a bunch of
seditious trees and his fox
want a traitors statue to stand on a
monument in richmond virginia course
they do why wouldn't they
so the real question to me is not where
this statue is going
the statue is is gone from the from the
public view in richmond virginia now it
belongs any anywhere that isn't a public
space making a public statement
about robert e lee and the reason why uh
the statue was there in the first place
was to intimidate black people
say hey
you
you might have got your freedom but you
didn't really remember that remember
that and that's why they're pissed off
now we're still going through this [__]
they're still trying to hold on to their
[__] their white power here
that they think they have
the american taliban i'll get to that
phrase here in a minute
because some people are pissed off about
that phrase american taliban or
christian taliban or texas taliban i'll
get to that phrase here in a minute
but my question is about this statue and
that monument that's standing there
is what what statue is going to go on
top of that monument
who could actually be
honored as a hero in richmond virginia
well i have a suggestion i have a
suggestion because i posed this question
you noticed in the clip this morning on
the on the twitch stream
when we were talking about and showing
the video of the the robert e lee statue
coming down off the monument
and i i got to thinking maybe maybe i
should find someone and
propose a candidate i'm not saying this
is the person that should be there i'm
just saying this might be a candidate
a proposal as it were to figure out
maybe who should go up on that monument
that's from richmond virginia
so a couple years after the civil war
there was a woman
who was born and then her married name
was maggie l walker from richmond
virginia maggie l walker is known as the
very first black businesswoman
to
actually charter a bank
in the united states she was also the
very first black woman to serve as
president
uh of a bank
in the united states she's from richmond
virginia her mother was a slave
uh
because of course she was born a couple
years after the civil war ended in
virginia
her mom was freed after the war
and
maggie was a very very very successful
businesswoman
from richmond virginia now i'm just
making a suggestion here i'm not saying
that that she should be the one i'm just
uh giving
nominate her candidacy
out there maybe i'll tweet about it
later that maggie l walker should be the
one
uh that is a candidate for a statue on
top of that monument in virginia because
there should be a hero standing on top
of that monument in a public space one
that we could all be proud of one that
we could tell stories about
i didn't know the story of maggie l
walker until i started doing a little
searching finding out who from richmond
virginia could be possibly deemed as an
american hero on that
on that platform
that monuments platform
so her candidacy sounds like a pretty
good candidacy now i don't know i don't
know if we get all democratic and vote
on this thing and throw in a bunch of
names but i nominate if that's the case
i nominate maggie l walker
an african-american businesswoman from
richmond virginia who is the very first
black woman charter president of a bank
excuse me president of a bank charter
that's who i nominate
not robert e lee or stonewall jackson
not traitors
that's a good start not a [__]
traitor
i'm gonna put up this tweet here so you
can see it i know i had it up on the
video but
uh i want to re-read it here because uh
robert e lee is a sucker and a loser
and this shouldn't it shouldn't be
controversial take down the trader
statue it should not it should not be a
controversial thing
if if you if you love your country and
you are a [__] patriot to the country
and you're not a [__] traitor
then you would probably not see this as
controversial
because real americans learn their
history and know the [__] truth
and if you learn the real [__]
history and know the [__] truth you
would know
that
you wouldn't put
a [__] statue of robert e lee up
as a hero
not a hero
not
a hero
so
speaking of real americans i don't know
maybe we'll get to this real quick i'll
slam dunk this [__] in the trash
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan of
course jim i don't report sex crimes
jordan probably thinks robert e lee is a
real american
oh i love robert e lee
that guy tried to overthrow the
government of the united states just
like i did
he was a general of the confederacy i'm
a general of the y'all kind of cheeto
dust confederacy we got so much in
common
[__] knucklehead
so jim jordan of course you know he
tweets out a couple different uh
[__] things about america and you
know trying to prove that he's a patriot
he's a patriot
and probably by the time i get done with
this podcast he's going to be tweeting
something about how he loves robert e
lee
but he tweets out yesterday
at uh real america quote unquote real
america as opposed to fake america
uh is done with covet 19.
so he's saying
that
we're just going to ignore it no [__]
sherlock we know you're ignoring you've
been ignoring it for a year and a half
that's why i say on the last one on the
last thing about robert e lee know your
history and know the truth
the more you know the truth the safer
you're gonna be the better off that it's
gonna be for everybody
well you know
when your daily lunch is peanut butter
and ivermectin sandwiches
it's probably hard to get tethered to
the truth a little bit
but what i said what i said because if
you if you go to the tweet here for him
which i didn't you know necessarily want
to show his whole tweet uh real america
is done with kobe 19 there's a there's
and he says god bless of course he says
that but there's a there's a video of a
college football game and
they're all cheering and having fun and
you know spreading coronavirus around
which there's there's a lot of nuance
even in just that video but
i said real america
meaning what he's talking about he's
saying white america that's what he's
saying white rule america that's what
he's saying
that's what he's saying he's
he means he means white people
white conservatives white republicans
evangelical cueing on trump pumpers
that's what he's saying real america you
know amer they're they're
switching around america first and now
it's real america i said real america
needs to pluck its head out of its
[__] ass
pace gobblers eating peanut butter and i
remembered sandwiches is it gonna stop
stupor spreader events
they need to [__] mask up and get
vaccinated if they want to be real true
patriot americans
the other [__] tweet that he sent out
is he said that vaccine mandates are
unamerican
what
what the [__] are you talking we've had
vaccine mandates for hundreds of years
you stupid bastard
i mean george washington during the
revolutionary war required his soldiers
to get inoculated from smallpox so it
wouldn't kill his entire army that way
we could have a country you stupid [__]
george washington had enough [__]
brains
oh oh maybe i should inoculate my army
of smallpox so it doesn't kill him that
way i have an army to fight so we have a
revolution oh that's a good idea
[__] boneheads
george washington didn't inoculate his
entire army from smallpox to control
them
to put a computer chip in them
oh it's just to hamper your freedom and
your rats
they were fighting for freedom and
rights and ultimately gain their liberty
and how they gain that liberty you
[__] boneheads was to be inoculated
from smallpox so it didn't [__] kill
them so they could fight for their
freedom and rights which would deliver
liberty to them
you people really are [__] dumb
really are [__] dumb especially you
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
an american
george washington's un-american folks
the revolutionary war
un-american
what the [__] are you talking about the
[__] out of here
this [__] and we got these other we got
other [__]
with this white male fragility just
whining crying
why are you crying about the white male
fragility like matt walsh this [__]
idiot
he's basically saying in this tweet i'm
not even gonna read it because he's just
whining here he's whining about women
being being sportscasters
just whining about it and how oh they're
taking away men's thing
so the whiny douchebag matt walsh is is
is saying we shouldn't be whining about
his opinion on female sports casters
okay you whiny little [__]
and it it just continues with these
[__]
continues and continues with this
american white male fragility christian
taliban
here we are back to the phrase
texas taliban american taliban christian
taliban because i get a lot of people
saying oh you don't need to bring race
and religion into it well it is about
religion it's not about
muslims
it's about right wing
religious fundamentalist
that's what it's about
whether you're muslim jewish christian
doesn't matter
doesn't matter what religion what race
what color
it's about
religious
fundamentalist
male religious fundamentalist
that's why they're the texas taliban
because as you know the taliban has
taken over the entire country of
afghanistan and there's already pictures
of of of their tolerance
i don't know if you've seen this but
there was a picture of a classroom where
it had women on one side men on the
other now the women
weren't fully covered
and they were in a classroom they were
allowing that but they had this big
curtain to separate the two
because
you know
you can't put men with women because
funny things happen
which i have i have a tick tock video
about that
i
i have a tick tock video it's not mine
this time it's not mine
uh
it was going around twitter and i've got
two parts
the first part was going around twitter
uh and it was this white fragile male
he's
a
[__] trump hump and evangelical
probably
he uh
he had cost a group of women on the
beach they're on a beach these women are
in swimsuits and he's offended
he offended that
that they have skin
he's offended
that they have skin oh my god imagine a
woman having skin oh
oh the horrors
so it costs these this group of women
won't leave them the [__] alone and the
part one is circulating around uh
twitter but i went and found part two on
tick tock and i want to play both parts
for you and kind of give you a little
commentation but it goes back to this
this christian taliban these this white
male fragility in this country
they think they have the right to tell
other people what the [__] to do
so let's let's watch part one and then
we'll we'll talk about it and then we'll
go to part two i want to show you part
two right here
right here on youtube right on the
podcast so you can hear part two to the
ending of this thing
okay
why do you dress this way
and i like women so please leave us
alone
kindly take take i'm at the beach in my
bathing suit that's that's a thong and
that's a brawl the eyes are [__]
bathing suits young guys into
consideration they don't need to see
pornography right we're not coming up to
you bothering you please go home you're
flaunting your stuff i'm not slothing
anything don't look at me
you look around and you know the only
thing that sticks out because your whole
body okay well why are you looking at me
close your eyes what did you just say is
your eyes out if i [__] bother you to
talk to me here's the thing
you didn't you didn't but here's the
thing there's free will in america
there's freedom of speech
don't stand up
then our society is going to go
go down the drain because there's no
atheist sorry
okay
that's if you're an atheist that doesn't
mean you have to
you know show your body off you can
still put clothes on
[Laughter]
so embarrassing i can't i'm speaking
truth your body will never ever satisfy
you the physical never ever satisfy
there's a longing in each of your hearts
to actually be seen the reason why the
reason why you're showing your body
because you're like
am i pretty enough
we're
next time you come to a beach and
there's young eyes take that into
consideration
is
[Music]
okay so we have and
what appears to be
uh a fragile whiny little [__] white
man
deciding it's his prerogative
to go across a group of women in bathing
suits
this is really [__] stupid this is
really [__] stupid i would almost
imagine i would almost imagine that this
dumb [__] has showed up at a few
rallies saying my body my choice with
mask
with mask
because he probably walks into grocery
stores without covering his [__]
ivermectin infected blowhole
this guy is a turd now there's all kinds
of stuff to unpack here
number one what is this guy if he's so
concerned about how these people look
why is he looking at them in the first
place
why is he even looking and number two
and you're gonna see this in part two
he's really upset about the language
that they're using people are upset
about the language that they're using
well they weren't
using this language i mean as far as i
know until he accosted him
and then the part the part where he's
really trying to bible thump him is
[__] hilarious
[__] hilarious because that's all
this this abortion law down in texas is
doing is bible thumping women telling
women what they can and can't do based
on the laws of god
you know like sharia law
the laws of god
look i'm not saying texas taliban or
christian taliban or american taliban or
al-qaeda
because of these people's ethnicity
because let me get something straight
if this if this video
was in kabul as opposed to america
think about this for a second if this
video was shot in kabul as opposed to
america
one would think one would think that
that man might have got out a whip and
started whipping them women for being
dressed the way they were dressed and
not being covered up
oh you're hurting my sensitive eyes with
your skin
why the [__] is nudity such a taboo
thing in the first place
i mean like the girl said the dude the
dudes are running around without their
[__] shirts on well that's different
that's different they're men
they're responsible with their nudity
you are irresponsible with yours
i mean your nudity leads to pregnancy
because it makes men like me horny and
because i have a boner i'm afraid
stop looking at him dumb [__]
don't pay attention to him pay no mind
leave them the [__]
alone
just like you should leave everyone else
leave them the [__] alone
and we're going to get to the greg
abbott texas
texas thing here in a minute but i want
to show you part two of this video
because it was just part one that was
kind of going around twitter so i want
to show you part two
because it gets a little more hairy here
and there's another person that gets
involved in the back and forth uh you
seen her in the first video and they
kind of point her out and talk about her
and then she comes over and gives her
opinion
which is just as bad as the other dude's
so let me let me play let me play that
[__]
that that's that's simply because
that's not even a bathing suit what
would you like me to wear what would you
like what do you consider a bathing suit
or a two piece or something like this
that's actually modest because you don't
need to be showing your body please just
leave us alone leave us alone please
thank you
i'm just saying i hope this actually
pull your head out of your eyes
and he says it's better did you know god
says do not be judged
oh and if you find someone's body
distracting then gouge your [__] eyes
out yeah
what do you mean why are you judging me
what do you mean you're judging me
i have children and i know you guys care
about kids i do and you're trying to
leave us alone he just came up to us
unprovoked please i don't know so he's
going away okay but i want you guys to
think about the fact
that what you guys are doing here does
matter to kids and i think you will have
that and i'm not
i'm judging you i'm not judging you i
have nothing to say
as far as this goes but you have to
leave my kids where i draw the line
[Music]
so there you have it there's part two uh
that the part that it that part one
didn't show is where he really gets the
bible out and starts to try to thump him
with the bible and they just they wad it
up and throw it right back in his face
which good for them [__] him
[__] him
and then the lady comes over and she
decides that she's gonna chime in
uh because they pointed her out
if you can't see the video because
you're listening to this on a podcast
the guy that's talking points out
another woman on the beach who has a
two-piece on but it isn't a bikini style
two-piece
and she comes over and decides to chime
in because they kind of brought her into
the conversation and she was close by
with children well the only reason why
these girls are yelling and cussing is
because this guy won't leave him the
[__] alone
the [__] away from me and besides my
words are not gonna hurt your children
the idea that women are are not
can't show their bodies and can't can't
like their bodies
teaching your children that this
bonehead saying this [__]
teaching your children is hell a lot
worse and your children learning the
word [__]
you dumb [__]
devaluing a woman because she's wearing
a certain piece of clothing on a beach
is a hell of a lot more detrimental to
your [__] kids than the word [__]
okay
ideas are a hell of a lot more potent
than words
then a word oh you said [__] oh my god
oh
who could imagine you said [__]
i mean here's a guy accosting a group of
young women telling them that they need
to cover their bodies because they
should be ashamed because of god in the
bible and who god who knows what else
because he's got a half a chub and he
can't control himself when he sees women
in bikinis he's just uncontrollable what
am i gonna do
god cannot control me and i cannot
control myself
so
so he has to accost these women well
that that is a hell of a lot worse and
hell a lot more detrimental lesson and
hell of a lot more detrimental to your
kids seeing
you [__] bonehead go sit down
and this is this is continuing and
continuing and continuing and continuing
this white male fragility this chris
american christian evangelical taliban
hanging on hanging on to the last thread
of what they call their country it's our
country we're gonna take it back
it's all the [__] that these schools are
about that's what this vaccine's about
oh i trust god i trust god god will save
me
god will save me
and then get into the my body my choice
which we're going to get to that really
quick here because i want to talk
because we got about 20 20 minutes left
and i want to talk about this greg
abbott thing
i want to talk about this [__] texas
login i am [__] sick and tired of
this and the one thing i want the point
i kind of want to get to today is
because i made several points about this
on other podcasts and other streams is
the point that i want to make about this
is the political point because a lot of
people a lot of people
are talking about the law itself and i
have two but a lot of people are also
trying to pay attention to what the
political ramifications of this are
and i think the political ramifications
of this are huge
and they're not good they're not good
for the gqp
i think they way miscalculated like they
always do they always miscalculate
they've always got a miscalculation
always
they always think they can do whatever
the [__] they want to do and get away
with it it's our country we're white
it's our country we're men it's our
country and we can do whatever the [__]
we want to do you know like joe rogan
type [__]
america's about doing whatever the [__]
you want to do whenever you want to do
it
to whoever you want to do i mean as long
as you're a white man
so greg abbott has a press conference
about the election law
they're signing the election bill of
course
not only are trying to take away the
right for a woman uh to say what she can
and can't do with her uterus and winning
when where she can't do that
they're also telling people well
you might want to stop us with the vote
but here's the thing
we're gonna make sure you can't vote
because that's what this [__]
election bill the suppression bill is
designed to do in texas it's designed to
suppress the vote of the people who
wouldn't [__] vote for them in the
first place
so they don't get voted out
so they can't you know get these laws
like this [__] stupid abortion bill
which is totally unconstitutional
and piece by piece by peace and i
believe that's how this wall law is
going to be torn down piece by piece by
piece and we're going to start seeing
these lawsuits quick fast and in a hurry
as this thing is implemented
and it starts to affect the lives
well-being and health care of [__]
women in texas
so after during the press conference
after the signing a reporter asked
greg abbott about the exceptions to
abortion rape incest
why why aren't those in this bill
why weren't they why weren't those part
of the bill the exceptions you know the
thing that everyone generally says and
we got to be careful about this because
we don't want it even the pro-life
movement and that's what i'm going to
talk about here in a minute
is why the pro-life movement hasn't
hasn't tried this this tactic
for for 50 years and they're just now
trying this
because they've had this in their back
pocket the whole time but there's been
reasons why they haven't done this and
we're going to experience it in real
time why
but the exceptions because there's
always been these exceptions because
it's hard it's hard to really explain
away how you're going to force a 13 year
old girl to carry her brother to full
term
it's really hard to explain
away the fact that you're gonna make a
rape victim carry their rapist child
to full term
it's hard to explain those types of
things away
the other thing that's hard to explain
away is the exception of the woman's
life
and her ability to have more children
you think that would be the one
exception that they would love the most
pro-lifers right pro-life pro-life the
woman's life if we can save the woman's
life the woman who wants to have more
children
you think that would be a thing
nope
because what greg abbott said is the
only exception the only exception here
is if you have abortion before six weeks
because if you really think about it i
mean
most men
okay
all men do not really think about this
they don't
men do not think about the six week
thing
men don't get pregnant
men don't have a menstrual cycle
we don't have those things
greg abbott
all the men who [__] decided this was
a great idea
we don't have those things and if you go
ask a woman
any of them
they would tell you that a menstrual
cycle
is almost six [__] weeks
so that's why you don't really know if
you're pregnant within six weeks it
seems as if
it seems as if these these white men
these christian taliban these white
american
fragile
christian taliban texas taliban
it's almost like they've noticed
that the menstrual cycle is damn near
six weeks and it would almost be
impossible
for a woman to know if she is pregnant
six weeks from her last menstrual cycle
it would it seem
really kind of it really kind of seems
like that would be the case
but here's what greg abbott
in his answer
points to
he goes straight not for the woman's
life
and that is very important here that is
crucial here
he skips over the exception for incest
he skips over the exception for the
woman's life they haven't abandoned
that woman's life thing they've
abandoned it and that is super [__]
important in the politics and i'm gonna
tell you why here in a minute about the
pro-life movement
that's super that's super super [__]
important he skips totally over that
and he goes straight for the rape
straight for the rape
and he's basically saying with his
answer that hey you got six weeks
if you get raped
if you get raped you got six weeks to
get an abortion
i mean come on how much time do you need
that's what he's saying
that's what the [__] he's saying in that
in that when he's saying it
now he also says and a lot of people
pointed this out about the the movie
minority report
you guys have seen this movie the
minority report mo movie with the
tom cruise where they can see
future crimes and they stop people from
committing future crimes
well that's what he that's everyone
jumped on that because he says well
texas is going to work tirelessly now
that we have passed this law
and rapist can be a career opportunity
in texas because the rapist can rape the
woman impregnate her and and collect a
bounty honor if she gets an abortion
it's a career opportunity but you know
what we're gonna work tirelessly here in
texas to prosecute every single one of
them rapists and take them off the
streets why aren't you doing that
already
how
you jester you just now are thinking
that that's a good idea greg abbott
to put all your thrust and all the
state's power into taking rapists off
the streets now that you pass this law
that basically allows men to freely rape
women and collect bounties on the
aborted on the aborted fetus
you're just now thinking about this
just now
huh
kind of convenient
so everyone really knocked him on this
the rapist thing
but politically politically if you
listen if you listen to what he said but
more importantly what greg abbott did
not say
and that's one of the most important
parts and actually yesterday i did a
stream on twitch where we were looking
through twitter
and uh at keeptroyblue
on on tiktok did a great video that i
just happened to come across
as i was scrolling through i didn't go
to his video we're just scrolling
through we're just surfing
surf and surf and tic tac
and troy's video comes up
and he makes great points in the video
so i want to play
i want to play uh the entirety of that
clip and it's a little long here but he
makes some good points and i want to
talk about the political ramifications
of the pro-life movement in this country
and and why
why they are ch they're reversing course
here totally on their 50-year battle of
roe v wade
because they're desperate here this is
this is the last stand now that they got
their supreme court justices
this is their last this is the hoorah
here this is the finale
and i want to explain to you why they're
doing what they're doing and why they're
abandoning
the woman's health here so let's let's
play this clip it's a little long but
hang with us you're on to me i hate them
babies just don't tell my wife and my
one-year-old daughter okay that's gonna
be an awkward conversation what are you
like eight years old yeah i'm pro-choice
i'm pro-reproductive freedom that
doesn't mean i [__] hate babies what
is wrong with you you guys have such a
black and white way of thinking about
the world
you know there are multiple nuanced
reasons to believe in things you can be
anti-war and still support the troops
you can be anti-capitalist and still
love freedom it's not about hating
babies it's about health care and health
care decisions and who has the right to
make those decisions first of all the
vast majority of abortions don't even
require an abortive surgery they're done
through an abortion pill but of the
abortions that do make it to the surgery
stage
the vast vast majority are done within
the first trimester usually within 12
weeks when the baby's just a clump of
cells it's not even a baby you guys are
seriously under the delusion that people
make it to like eight months nine months
in their pregnancy and then go oh you
know what i don't want it [__] kill
it that literally never [__] happens
if somebody's having an abortion that
late it's because of a medical necessity
they're not waiting nine months and then
deciding to use abortion as birth
control at nine months you have the room
decorated you have the name picked out
you're bringing home toys from your
friends and dr hand me down clothes
that's not when you decide to have an
abortion at that period you're counting
the minutes from the time the baby
stopped kicking
because you're so [__] afraid that if
it doesn't kick it's dead are you a
father are you a parent do you know how
this thing works no do you know how the
psycho the parent works nobody kills
their own [__] children because it's
because it gets them off because it's a
hobby my wife had a procedure at eight
weeks to get rid of an ectopic pregnancy
it's called a dnc essentially they go in
and they scrape out the baby it's an
abortive procedure it's the same
procedure they use an abortion the baby
was already dead because it was an
ectopic pregnancy well technically it
was still alive but it was more of like
a parasite it would have killed my wife
if we had left it in but the insurance
company coded it as an abortion because
it's a typical abortion procedure what's
to say in some of these states where
they're outlawing they have blanket
outlaws and he's making a really good
point here because a dnc which you know
he's not a woman i'm not a woman we
would never have a dnc but a dnc is a is
a very uh
common procedure in that it saves the
woman's life so what happens what
happens in texas now if a woman receives
a dnc or she has to cross a state line
and is it does someone get a bounty on
her or how many people get bounties
that's what i want to know too let's say
this woman lives in a really crowded
neighborhood and about 20 of her
neighbors find out that she has had a
dnc to save her life to all 20 people
get to sue her because they're offended
think about that do all 20 of them i
mean really
i mean honestly
why not why why wouldn't 20 people or is
it only one bounty is it only one bounty
or anyone who wants a bounty which is it
which is it texas which is it
men who don't have uteruses that are
making laws for people who do have
uteruses called women
which is it
let's listen to the rest of the video
because of a board of procedures that my
wife would not have been able to get
that procedure to rid herself with that
ectopic pregnancy in which case she
would have [__] died and my
one-year-old living breathing daughter
would never have made to this world it's
literally none of your [__] business
why women choose to have an abortion
like none period across the board it's
not up to you it's their [__] body
they can do whatever the [__] they want
but it's only you small government types
that think it's the government's
responsibility to come and tell a woman
what she can do with her own [__]
reproductive organs kind of dystopian
[__] is that if you really were that
concerned about stopping unwanted
pregnancies and therefore stopping
abortions you'd mandate vasectomy
because men are capable of getting a
woman pregnant 365 days a year a woman
can only get pregnant once every nine
months
and i've seen a lot of people post this
that maybe maybe we should put
a bounty
on
on men i mean you know you could make
the argument that men actually get women
pregnant so maybe we should put the
bounty on men not women
maybe if you put the bounty on men
maybe that would change a whole hell of
a lot of minds about a law and bounties
i mean you know
if you if
if for some reason some reason you
decide to you know spank the old monk
maybe and someone finds out about it
maybe there should be a ten thousand
dollar bounty i mean you wasted all
all that seed
right and
[__] break
you don't want to take it that far
increase access to birth control and
comprehensive sex education baffles me
that you guys are anti-abortion and
anti-birth control it was never about
stopping abortion it's about controlling
women
and that's it it's all about controlling
women and the pro-life movement
uh
is out of balance here now
i want to be clear about something
the pro-life movement
came from the christian right wing in
the form of jerry falwell he really was
the architect of the pro-life movement
uh that piece of [__]
and he's
he's had
forced decades and decades and decades
of oppression on women and their medical
choices that they make for their own
[__] bodies
because as troy says in the video uh an
um a procedure like a dnc or even a dne
where where a woman's
health and their life is at risk
because of the quote-unquote pregnancy
the quote-unquote fetus the
quote-unquote embryo
so
that's where the pro-life movement's
lost your way i want to rewind your mind
a little bit
to back to 2016 there was two people
running for president one was a woman
one was a man
and the man
he
the person who was the candidate for the
republican party the white man the white
and title whiny little [__] of a man
went on chris matthew's show as a town
hall and if you remember if you remember
chris matthews asked him should a woman
who receives an abortion receive
punishment
through the criminal courts and donald
trump
shocked and awed
everyone when he said yeah probably why
not who knows he was trying to read the
room
and he did it basically on live
television now there was a lot of
rumbles throughout the pro-life movement
because the pro-life movement has never
really
never really took aim at a woman
right they've always taken aim at the
pro-choice
side of the argument they've always
taken aim at the abortion itself
never really
at the woman and here's why the pro-life
movement
has always blamed pro-choicers and
planned parenthood of being baby killers
because they they've always had this
narrative for years and years and years
that that planned parenthood and
abortion clinics and pro-choice people
they brainwash you
into believing you should get rid of the
baby
you know and they can it's kind of like
pray the gay way type [__] they can
bring the woman in and
and show her god and she'll see the way
and she'll see the light well what the
[__] does god have to do with a medical
decision that has to do with you saving
your [__] life or not
and the reason why the pro-life movement
has always had that stance is to not
target women directly with the [__]
bow and arrow as criminal
and this law is really inching up to
that now it's oh you're gonna be civilly
liable you're gonna have to pay ten
thousand dollars to anyone who wants to
sue you and that's my question is how
many people get to sue that woman how
many how [__] many
she can be liable for god knows how much
[__] bounty
because the entire block's gonna turn
her in the entire block's gonna sue her
because they know she had a life-saving
procedure to save her [__] life
like a dnc like troy's wife did
and the pro that's why the pro-life
movement when donald trump said that
they cringed they cringed because here's
one thing that the pro-life movement
knows
and this is one thing
that i think
is the miscalculation for republicans
here
is when you take the exception
of the woman's life
and the woman's healthcare choice based
on her life
her to be alive to be a mother or a
future mother to have kids or to take
care of the kids she already has you
know pro-life [__]
i believe i believe what will happen
is that even even women who lean to the
pro-life side of the argument
begin
to see the pro-life movement as full of
[__] [__] because that's what they've
always been
full of [__] [__]
it's a bunch of [__] christian males
telling women what to do because it's
not about pro-life
it's not because when you take the
exception of the woman's life out of the
equation it's not pro-life it's
anti-woman
they want to tell [__] women what to
do they want to tell them what to wear
they want to tell them they can't wear
sexy bikinis on a beach because it makes
them have a half a chub and by god i
can't trust myself when when i get horny
i can't trust myself
so you have to change your
your position you have to change what
you're doing to accommodate my white
male fragility
that's what it is
and a coalition that can be built around
the absence
of the of the mothers
of the woman's life
the coalition that can be about uh built
around that idea of the absence
of any kind of thought of the woman's
life
that coalition
could destroy the pro-life movement
because believe you me believe you me it
ain't just in texas missouri
south dakota with christie gnome
ron desantis in florida oh they're all
going to be competing
all going to be competing to make their
next law their next abortion bounty law
more [__] disgusting than the last
one
oh they're going to one-up each other
because they gotta they gotta placate to
the [__] fox news the oan and the
newsmax fans these [__] trump bumpers
we're at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life and on one
corner we have the ivermecton store and
on the other corner we have greg abbott
on a stage
telling women what the [__] to do with
their bodies
and the next one to come up on stage is
ron desantis and after that will be
christy gnome and mike parson and on and
on and on in these red states
and these laws are going to get more and
more [__] disgusting
and the challenge to challenges them are
going to get easier and easier as they
get more and more uns unconstitutional
because they don't give a [__] about the
constitution they proved that to us on
january 6 they don't give a [__]
they don't care about america they don't
want you to have liberty
they want to have the right and the
freedom to oppress you
that's what they want
that's their america that's what they're
missing we we're losing the right to
oppress you
what the [__]
this law is gonna be dangerous it's
gonna kill women it's not a pro-life law
it's a pro-death law
and the laws that come after this in
these other states are gonna be deadlier
and deadlier and deadlier
to women
because they don't have the autonomy to
make their medical decisions for their
[__] bodies
they've lost their liberty
and i believe
that the coalition that's gonna be
wrought against the pro-life movement
and the [__] gqp these cueing on
trump pumping evangelical [__]
christians the christian taliban as it
were in this country now who's trying to
oppress women
the coalition that's going to rain down
on them soon is going to be humongous
and i'll march with them and every man
out there should march with them too
so keep saying it loud
and keep voting vote vote
vote vote vote
organize organize organize
dust off dust off them [__] hats
and let's go marching
i'll see you next week [__] em you've
been listening to the tony michaels
podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them